en este vídeo quiero darles un último
ejemplo de una transformación antes de
que nos movamos directamente al cálculo
de varias variables así que en el vídeo
donde hablamos de superficies
parametrizados les di esta función de
aquí que de hecho tiene una expresión
bastante complicada verdad y en realidad
tiene una entrada de dos dimensiones y
una salida de tres dimensiones y
hablamos de cómo podríamos pensar esto
verdad dibujando una superficie en un
espacio de tres dimensiones y después
vimos que esta superficie en realidad
era una duna que también podríamos
llamar toro así que lo que quiero hacer
en este vídeo es hablar de cómo
podríamos pensar esta función como una
transformación y primero déjenme ir
directamente a lo que sería el espacio
de entrada verdad al espacio de entradas
así que esto en principio podría ser
todo el plano de ese verdad entonces
podríamos en principio pensar en el
plano ts aquí estaría el eje t
y de forma vertical tendríamos el eje s
verdad ahí tendríamos el eje s pero
todavía podríamos tomar un subconjunto
de esto verdad simplemente podríamos
limitarnos a tomarnos t de 0 a 2 pi aquí
estaría más o menos 2 pi y también lo
mismo podríamos hacer con ese verdad
vamos a tomar ese hasta el valor 2 muy
bien entonces podríamos imaginarnos que
en realidad estamos considerando una
región cuadrada más o menos
este cuadrado estamos considerando esta
región cuadrada donde aceite o té y es
más bien se mueven entre 0 y 2 y verdad
entonces sólo vamos a considerar los
puntos que necesitamos para dibujar el
toro y la razón básica por la cual
estamos tomando solo estos valores es
porque por ejemplo coseno de teo seno dt
o seno de s o coseno de de s en realidad
tienen estos son funciones periódicas de
periodo 2 y verdad entonces con esto
basta para cubrir todo el rango verdad
así que lo que podemos hacer es tomar
esta porción verdad del plano ts verdad
lo podríamos pensar como que vive en un
espacio también de tres dimensiones y en
realidad es un poquito de hacer trampa
digamos pero al menos es mucho más fácil
hacer esto que imaginarlo digamos
moviéndose de un área separada a otro
espacio verdad al menos al menos sirve
para la animación y es mucho más fácil
digamos empezar en el espacio de tres
dimensiones así que vamos a pensar que
este cuadrado
digamos que está en el plano ts está
metido en este espacio y para esta
función estaremos tomando todos los
puntos de este cuadrado como los valores
de entrada y las salidas de cada punto
estarán en el espacio de tres
dimensiones y podríamos pensar cómo es
que estos puntos se mueven a sus
correspondientes salidas así que te
mostraré nuevamente empezamos con
nuestro plano ts verdad que está por
aquí y dependiendo de cada punto de
entrada es digamos a dónde va a seguir
hacia su punto de salida verdad si
siguiéramos cada uno de estos puntos a
través de esta transformación el lugar a
donde cae sería digamos la salida
correspondiente de esta función y una de
las cosas que quizás debería mencionar
es que cada valor digamos que está
interpolado entre el valor inicial y el
final en realidad no importa en verdad
su función es la función es realmente
una cosa estática sólo hay una entrada y
hay una salida así que si pensamos en
términos de una transformación en
realidad moverlo de uno a otro es
digamos como como un poquito de magia
verdad es solo para que la animación se
vea
amigable verdad y en este caso lo estoy
mostrando digamos como en dos bases en
donde se van enrollando que en realidad
no importan pero la idea general es
empezar con un cuadrado y de alguna
forma transportarse hacia los valores de
salida verdad así que a medida que nos
adentramos en el cálculo de varias
variables y empecemos y vamos a pensar
un poquito más a profundidad en los
temas de superficies yo digo que
realmente ayuda a pensar cómo es que un
pequeño movimiento en el espacio de
entrada es verdad se vería reflejado en
un pequeño movimiento digamos en el
espacio de salida es verdad en nuestra
superficie ya tendremos más
oportunidades para engancharnos con
estas ideas de las superficies pero aquí
al menos solo quiero que sus mentes se
vayan acostumbrando a estas formas muy
bonitas de ver las funciones que estamos
construyendo